bien alors maintenant on va continuer on
va faire une petite interview alerte
bleue les robots l'air trop sur nos
grands classiques de cette émission est
ce que vous préférez draguer ou faire
draguer c'est pas comme ça que tu devras
gras embrassez vous faire embrasser les
deux mon capitaine
car et c'est alors qu'elle est le lieu
idéal pour faire l'amour donne ça dépend
des jours y'a pas un lieu idéal fait
répondu ça dépend de l'humeur ça dépend
de ce qu'on vit de comme on est à ce
moment là ya pas deux alors est-ce que
vous avez besoin de faire l'amour pour
aimer ou des mets pour faire l'amour
j'ai besoin d'aidé pour soi-même ou
quelle banque
vous commencez pas par faire l'amour
après vous aimez non non non préférez un
mec qui bosse bien mecha fidèles ou un
mec qui baisent mal mais les fidèles
pouvaient bien et et incident n a pas ce
que ça arrive parce qu'ils vont mettre à
plusieurs sur les bonnes affaires que
tout serait de mauvais goût
elle est beaucoup plus dans des boîtes
échangistes il ya un truc les rixes et
des hommes qui brandissent l'étendard de
la fidélité et qui en fait qui vous
ennuie sous prétexte qu'ils sont 6es
vous préférez le magazine amusé voilà
mais tu veux savoir
non mais tu te situes le tabac non mais
vous verrez voilà un mec qui chutent
bonne humeur quand il rentre c'est ce
que vous dites voilà sept jeunes ont
bien auprès des lectrices vous
préféreriez qui vous quitte pour un
homme pour une femme guide pour moi je
suis pas un homme super g dont voici ma
femme me quitter pour une femme je serai
moins jaloux pour un homme
je serais ravi surtout parce que si ça
prouverait que j'étais les femmes quand
même pas terrible
vous préférez qui couche avec une autre
en pensant à vous avec vous en tançant
une autre c'est avec les nôtres en
pensant à gérer ça avec la lumière bout
et qu'on allait s'aligner
où est un nom mais cbc serge préféré
c'est parce que tu peux baisser un peu
la rentrée vous pas ce qu'on va voir